examen de la proposition de résolution
l'application de l'article 34 1 de la
Constitution
visant à interdire l'importation de
produits issus du travail forcé de la
population
ouigo en République populaire de Chine
présenté par mandam Mélanie Vogel
monsieur Guillaume Gontard et plusieurs
voleurs collègues du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur Guillaume comptard auteur
de la proposition de résolution pour 10
minutes
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
à l'initiative de notre collègue Mélanie
Vogel qui regrette de ne pouvoir être
des nôtres aujourd'hui et que je vous
prie de bien vouloir excuser le groupe
écologiste solidarité et territoire
propose qu'à son tour le Sénat s'exprime
sur l'horreur sur l'indicible crime
contre l'humanité opérer méthodiquement
depuis plus de 10 ans dans l'ouest de la
Chine pour compléter la résolution votée
à l'Assemblée nationale nous vous
proposons de manière plus opérationnelle
de stopper l'importation des produits
issus du travail forcé des Wiggs en
France comme en Europe
mes chers collègues grâce à la
mobilisation de tous les instants de la
diaspora oui gourd relayez notamment par
notre collègue député européen Raphaël
Raphaël Glucksmann vous savez nous
savons beaucoup du traitement inhumain
dont est victime la monorité oui gourd
de Chine mais permettez-moi néanmoins de
rappeler une nouvelle fois l'ampleur de
l'horreur à l'oeuvre dans le King
Charles depuis le début des années 2010
et surtout depuis la section au pouvoir
de King la République populaire de Chine
adopte une stratégie d'assimilation
culturelle violente envers les groupes
minoritaires et particulièrement avec la
minorité musulmane ouigourd dans la
région autonome du meeting
cette politique d'épuration ethnique se
traduit par l'interdiction de pratiques
religieuses et culturelles la
destruction de lieux de culte et de
cimetière religieux ou encore la
surveillance de masse les autorités
chinoises font tout ce qui est en leur
pouvoir pour diminuer la présence de
l'islam le King se transforme en
laboratoire de la politique
d'assimilation répressive du Parti
communiste chinois
sous couvert de luttes antiterroriste le
gouvernement chinois criminalise tout
expression des traditions ouigo sous
couvert de luttes contre l'extrémisme
religieux le gouvernement chinois
s'octroi le droit d'incerer dans des
camps de rééducation toute personne qui
pratique la religion musulmane la
pratique du Ramadan la consommation de
nourriture anale une apparence du jet
trop religieuse ou encore l'enseignement
coranique suffisent à vous envoyer dans
un camp de rééducation où les deux
tenues sont forcés d'abandonner leur
religion et pour le prouver les
autorités chinoises les forces à boire
de l'alcool manger du porc ou encore
prêté allégeance aux parties communistes
chinois
d'autres témoignages issus de ces camps
notamment de femmes kazak ouigourt font
froid dans le dos il y ait fait état
d'un abodimidable contrôle des
naissances se traduisant par la pose
contrainte de contraceptif des
avortements et des stérilisations
forcées
les femmes récalcitrantes sont menacées
de sanctions et de détention ces mesures
visant à entraver les naissances au sein
du groupe représentant un élément
caractérisant une entreprise génocidaire
selon la définition juridique
internationale du génocide 1948 au
milieu des années 2010 les arêtes les
arrestations préventives et les
placements dans des camps se multiplient
avec des prétextes de plus en plus
dérisoires comme une sainte discussion
avec un résident étranger les
incarcérations se font naturellement en
dehors du système judiciaire des
dispositifs de surveillance massifs sont
mis en place pour traquer les musulmans
des fonctionnaires sont envoyés vivre
dans les familles musulmanes pour
surveiller leur mode de vie ce qu'elle
mange ou comment elles éduquent leurs
enfants
une Vasse politique de délation rappelle
les heures les plus sombes de l'histoire
de l'humanité et promu par les autorités
chinoises les 8 gours sont également
traqués à l'étranger les autorités
chinoises leur demandent des
informations sur le reste de la diaspora
en les menaçant de s'en prendre à leur
famille rester en Chine s'il refuse de
répondre c'est en 2017 que les premières
preuves de l'existence de ces camps
émergent et que les premières réactions
internationales se font entendre Amnesty
internationale et l'Organisation des
Nations unies estiment qu'il existe
1200cendes rééducation auxign et un
million de prisonniers un musulman sur 6
et concerné
quelques mois plus tard on découvre que
le gouvernement chinois organise un
système de travail forcé des Ouigours
dans un rapport des autorités chinoises
qui datent de 2020 nous apprenons que
2,6 millions de citoyens Ouigours du
sing Yang ont été placés dans des fermes
et des usines un système organisé au
plus haut niveau permet aux industriels
de passer des commandes de travailleurs
aux autorités locales des recruteurs
sont désignés avec des quotas de
travailleurs à atteindre ils se rendent
au sein des foyers pour recruter des
travailleurs tous les habitants
turcissiques de plus de 16 ans sont
susceptibles d'être forcés d'aller
travailler et sont menacés de détention
pendant quelques jours ils sont formés à
des tâches répétitives puis envoyer dans
les usines ils sont entassés dans des
dortoirs ne peuvent pas démissionner
travail pendant un nombre incalculable
d'heures et ont de très bas salaires
ces dernières années on a su se
construire dans la région on a vu se
construire pardon dans la région du King
d'immense complexes industriel parfois
au sein même des camps de rééducation le
secteur du textile est le plus concerné
et parmi les marques concernées on
trouve Adidas Zara Nike Uniqlo et bien
d'autres et d'autres secteurs sont
également mis en cause l'automobile les
jouets ou encore les panneaux solaires
disons le clairement c'est toute une
partie de l'appareil industriel chinois
auquel nous avons délégué la production
de tant d'objets de notre eau de
quotidien qui repose qui repose sur le
travail forcé commençons la production
industrielle soviétique mais alors notre
attitude était tout autre
tous ces agissements ont une
qualification ce sont des crimes contre
l'humanité c'est ce que confirme le 31
août 2022 Michel Bachelet alors au
commissaire des droits de l'homme la
haute commissaire rend un rapport
accablant résultat de sa visite aux
signes Chiang les conclusions de ce
rapport sont sans appel il confirme
toutes les révélations des associations
des défenses des droits de l'homme
malgré les nombreuses réactions
internationales très peu des marques
mises en cause ont répondu aux
accusations et celles qui t'ont arrêté
de faire appel aux usines du singe se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main vous
l'aurez compris les indignations de
suffisent plus leur coût politique est
économique et bien trop faible en 2021
le commerce direct entre le cynthiang et
l'Union européenne a même augmenté de
13,6%
. c'est tout un système économique
mondial basé sur le profit et
l'exploitation de la vie humaine qu'il
faut combattre aujourd'hui on sait que
potentiellement
un vêtement sur 5 porté sur la planète
peut-être entacher de travail forcé oui
Gour c'est vertigineux l'Europe doit
prendre ses responsabilités nous avons
le devoir de nous doter d'une politique
commerciale exigeante qui respecte les
droits humains les plus basiques les
initiatives dans ce sens se multiplient
et la France qui se veut le phare de la
promotion des droits partout dans le
monde doit produire son effort et son
effet en 2021 les États-Unis ont
interdit d'apporter des produits
fabriqués dans la province chinoise si
chinoise de xyang tout produit fabriqué
même partiellement aux Cink Yang est
issu du travail forcé et ne peut être
importé sauf si les entreprises sont en
mesure de fournir des preuves claires et
convaincantes du contraire dans le même
esprit la Commission européenne a
présenté au mois de septembre dernier un
projet qui permettrait à terme
d'interdire certains produits d'entrer
sur le marché européen
en cas de soupçon autour d'un produit
les organismes en charge de la
surveillance des marchés pourront lancer
une enquête préliminaire au terme de
cette enquête le produit soupçonné
pourrait être banni du marché européen
comme l'explique notre proposition de
résolution nous souhaiterions que la
France et l'Europe adopte une position
proche de celle des États-Unis en effet
nous pensons que la charge de la preuve
doit être inversée ce sont les
industriels qui doivent prouver de
manière convaincante qui ne se
fournissent pas dans des usines et qui
font appel au travail forcé des Ouigours
ce ne sont pas au pouvoir public ou au
lanceur d'alerte dans n'importe quel
épreuve
je précise au passage qu'adopter la
position américaine sur ce volet n'est
pas du tout synonyme dans notre esprit
d'un alignement complet avec des
positions américaines dans la guerre
commerciale parfois quelque peu
manichéenne engagées contre la Chine au
regard des bouleversements géopolitiques
majeurs que nous connaissons ces
dernières années l'Europe et la France
sont dans la nécessité impérieuse de
redéfinir leurs relations avec la Chine
et de construire une politique chinoise
qui nous soit propre au regard des
valeurs portées par notre pays et notre
union continentale la fermeté absolue
vis-à-vis des crimes contre l'humanité
doit pour nous constituer une composante
essentielle de notre relation avec Pékin
alors que l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
en janvier 2022 une proposition de
résolution portant sur la reconnaissance
et la condamnation du caractère
génocidaire des violences politiques
systématiques ainsi que des crimes
contre l'humanité actuellement perpétré
par la République populaire de Chine à
l'égard des Ouigours comment
pouvons-nous continuer à importer vendre
et consommer des produits qui sont
clairement fabriqués dans des conditions
de travail forcé et qui n'ont pas grand
chose à envier au goulag il est plus que
logique et cohérent aujourd'hui de
demander au gouvernement d'adopter de
vraies mesures efficaces pour cesser
selon les mots de notre collègue Mélanie
vosgel d'offrir un débouché commercial
au crime contre l'humanité en mettant en
place une politique qui rejette tout
produit
issu du travail forcé des Ouigours la
France ferait peser une vraie chape de
plomb sur la Chine qui mise énormément
sur les développements de la région du
cygiang région en cœur du projet de
nouvelles routes de la soie en lien avec
la position géographique
au croisement de route commerciale entre
les continents européens et asiatiques
le seul rapport de force que comprend la
Chine est économique et c'est à son
portefeuille qu'il faut s'attaquer pour
tenter de retrouver le sens de notre
humanité merci
[Applaudissements]
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Monsieur Thomas dessus pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
mes chers collègues je remplace ma
collègue Mélanie Vogel initiatrice pour
notre groupe de ce texte depuis 2017 des
millions de membres d'hôtes minorités
musulmanes ont disparu dans un vaste
réseau de camps de rééducation dans la
région du cynthiang
un programme de génocide culturel mené
par le gouvernement chinois des femmes
subissant des stérilisations forcées des
détenus soumis à un endocrinement
politique contraint de renoncer à leur
religion alors culture soumis à la
torture cela fait maintenant trois ans
que l'australiane stratégique policine
située a rendu son rapport sur le
travail forcé de la population ouigo 3
ans que la liste de la honte recensant
83 marques dans le secteur de la
technologie de l'industrie et surtout de
la mode a mis au jour l'utilisation
massive par des grandes marques du
système contre concentrationnaire mis en
place dans le signe Chang par la
République populaire de Chine que
s'est-il passé depuis quelques marques
comme Adidas ou Nike ont annoncé avoir
cessé de s'approvisionné au sing Shang
certaines comme Zara ou Hugo Boss ont
condamné le système avant de revenir sur
leur déclaration pour ne pas froisser en
Chine et beaucoup d'autres ont
simplement resté silencieuses dans les
faits rien n'a changé les associations
comme Sherpa ou l'Institut ouigo en
Europe ont déposé de nombreuses plaintes
es mais 20% du coton mondial est
toujours produit dans la région autonome
du signe Chiang donc dans notre
hémicycle aujourd'hui les vêtements que
nous portons les téléphones dans nos
poches les écrans dans cette salle sont
très certainement produits en partie au
prix d'un peuple réduit en esclavage le
système de trade des êtres humains mis
en place contre les wigours est un
moteur de la politique industrielle de
la République populaire de Chine le
carburant sanglant de la stratégie
commerciale des nouvelles routes de la
soie du gouvernement de Pékin
un million voire probablement 2 millions
de personnes enfermées dans des camps de
travail enfermés et torturé parfois
simplement pour avoir parlé leur langue
dans la rue ou avoir appelé quelqu'un à
l'étranger on parle ici de 10% de la
population ouigo aujourd'hui le Sénat
peut regarder avec les yeux grands
ouverts la réalité que le régime chinois
veut masquer étouffer nier nous sommes
face à la plus grande campagne
d'internement d'une population depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale alors que fait
concrètement la France trop peu hélas
bien sûr symboliquement l'Assemblée
nationale a reconnu par résolution
l'année dernière qu'il s'agissait d'un
crime contre l'humanité et nous le
saluons mais après rien ne fait vraiment
obstacle à la circulation en Europe des
produits issus du travail forcé
aujourd'hui nous vous invitons à avancer
sur cette question fondamentale en
demandant au gouvernement français de
travailler à l'échelle européenne le
plus grand marché mondial à mettre en
place un véritable mécanisme de contrôle
des produits issus du travail forcé en
Chine nous souhaitons ici nous inspirer
de ce que font déjà les États-Unis et le
Canada entre autres en inversant la
charge de la preuve oui aux États-Unis
depuis l'an dernier si un produit a été
fabriqué tout en tout ou partie dans le
signe Shang il est considéré a priori
comme
issu du travail forcé après avoir
ensuite aux entreprises de prouver le
contraire résultat une baisse remarquée
des importations provenances de Chine
aux États-Unis qui malheureusement s'est
accompagné d'une augmentation en même
temps des importations chinoises en
France il nous faut donc désormais nous
aussi demander aux entreprises qui
souhaitent accéder au marché commun
européen de prouver noir sur blanc la
traçabilité de leurs produits
et qui laisse en reproche à ce moment en
ce moment même à Bruxelles on s'apprête
malheureusement à mettre en place le
processus inverse un processus lu un
processus un processus long et compliqué
difficilement lisible qui impose aux
États membres de fournir eux-mêmes la
preuve du travail forcé pour interdire
les produits incriminés un processus
absurde et inefficace tout le contraire
de ce qu'il faudrait faire donc à
l'inverse cette résolution celle que
nous proposons d'adopter aujourd'hui est
une proposition de bon sens la
représentation nationale a déjà condamné
le caractère génocidaire des violences à
l'encontre des wigours soyons cohérents
soyons logiques traduisons ces
intentions dans les actes comment
dénoncer un crime contre l'humanité et
en rester là sans interdire sur notre
sol les fruits de ce crime il en va de
l'honneur de la France d'être le moteur
à l'échelle européenne d'une initiative
claire nette qui ferait véritablement
obstacle à la circulation des produits
de l'esclavage moderne ce serait un
message clair et puissant vous voyez non
seulement à l'adresse de Pékin mais qui
aurait aussi un caractère universel le
travail forcé l'esclavage moderne ne
doit pas seulement être dénoncé il doit
être également dans les faits rendus
impossible c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons initié ces proposition de
résolution et c'est la région pour
laquelle nous groupe écologistes alors
bien évidemment nous prononcer en sa
faveur je vous remercie merci chers
collègues dans la suite de la discussion
la parole est à Monsieur André gatolin
pour le groupe RDPI pour 6 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je veux
tout d'abord remercier le groupe geste
qui est à l'origine du texte que nous
étudions aujourd'hui d'abord parce que
c'est la première fois je dis bien la
première fois que notre Haute Assemblée
est amenée à débattre de l'abominable
tragédie qui frappe la population huit
Gourg disons-le il était temps quand il
y a 10 ans j'ai pris l'initiative
d'inviter les représentants du Congrès
mondial oui gourd dans nos murs j'avoue
que j'ai ressenti comme un grand moment
de solitude car rare était à l'époque
les parlementaires un temps soit peu
informé de cette effroyable drame
depuis la coercition massive exerçait à
l'encontre de cette minorité technique
n'a cercé de s'intensifier et il aura
fallu l'incroyable persévérance de
quelques associations et de quelques
chercheurs pour parvenir à documenter ce
que deux corps
osent désormais appelé un véritable
processus génocidaire même si le travail
forcé ne constitue qu'une des multiples
exactions mises en oeuvre par le régime
de Pékin à l'encontre des huit gourgs
cette proposition de résolution est
aussi l'occasion de parler de cette
forme d'esclavage moderne qui est
aujourd'hui en forte résurgence en Chine
et aussi d'autres pays dans le monde la
lutte contre ce fléau remonte à 1930
puisque la convention visant à combattre
le travail forcé fut parmi les premières
adoptées par l'Organisation
internationale du travail créé en 1919
s'en est suivi l'adoption d'une seconde
convention posant l'abolition de ce
travail forcé en 1957 sur le papier nous
pourrions nous réjouir que la
quasi-totalité des états de la planète
est aujourd'hui ratifié ces deux
conventions très récemment le 12 août
2022 la République populaire de Chine a
à son tour fini par les ratifier et le
rentrer en application et supposé
intervenir d'ici à deux mois et demi on
pourrait croire si on était naïf
l'affaire plier et l'objet de la
présente résolution nulle et non avenues
mais mes amis le fait les faits sont
têtus et la réalité terriblement coriace
loin de régresser le travail forcé
connaît une recrudescence très
inquiétante depuis le milieu des années
2010 le it estime à 28 millions de
personnes les victimes du travail forcé
dans le monde en 2021 un chiffre en
progression de près de 3 millions par
rapport à 2016 pour des raisons très
politiques l'OIT de donner
un pays mais seulement des agrégats
régionaux heureusement nous en sauvons
davantage grâce à la Fondation walk Free
qui vient de publier son dernier rapport
il y a une semaine exactement dans son
index mondial qui agrège travail forcé
mariage forcé et traite une main et le
fait apparaître que la Chine avec 5,8
millions de personnes soumises à ces
femmes scandaleuses esclavage moderne se
situe au second rang mondial derrière
l'Inde en Chine continentale ce chiffre
a même connu une progression de 70% au
cours des cinq dernières années au
contraire de l'Inde où le travail forcé
est plus diffus sur l'ensemble du
territoire le phénomène en Chine est
davantage concentré dans les régions
comme le shinyang et où le Tibet et il
est comme en Corée du Nord le fruit
d'une politique délibérée de l'État et
non celui d'acteurs privés comme dans la
plupart des autres pays il serait
illusoire de croire que la ratification
des deux conventions de l'iroité
afficheront les choses en Chine et aux
chignan en particulier car qui aloyité
sera autorisé à aller sur le terrain
vérifier leur application rappelons-nous
mes chers collègues la tragique comédie
de la mission d'inspection de l'OMS en
janvier février 2021 ou laboratoire de
virologie à ouhan rappelons-nous le
fiasco du déplacement de Michel Bachelet
au chilian en mai 2022 il y a 10 ans je
rappelle que la Chine a officiellement
aboli la rééducation par le travail le
seul véritablement véritable changement
a été la requalification sémantique des
camps de rééducation en centre de
formation professionnelle en réalité
cette ratification par la Chine des
conventions de l'OIT est une tentative
de fournir un alibi à la Commission pour
ouvrir la ratification de l'accord
global sur les investissements Union
européenne Chine signée en catimini de
30 décembre 2020 il a été suspendu après
le tollé provoqué notamment par les
sanctions imposées à Pékin à plusieurs
euros députés défendant la cause de
ouigo pour ne pas perdre la phase devant
l'opinion publique européenne la
commission tant actuellement de
finaliser un règlement interdisant
l'importation des produits
issus du travail forcé mais en l'état
elle n'est pas dotée des moyens
nécessaires pour en assurer la
traçabilité effective la grande
faiblesse du texte de la commission
c'est de faire peser la charge de la
preuve sur le régulateur régulateur qui
a déjà bien du mal à assurer un suivi
systématique des accords commerciaux
dont elle a la responsabilité et
l'intérêt majeur de la résolution ici en
discussion et précisément de faire
porter la charge de la preuve aux
entreprises responsables de
l'introduction de ces produits sur le
marché européen il ne s'agit en rien
d'une mesure d'exception elle est
conforme au droit européen et s'applique
déjà dans plusieurs domaines je rappelle
ici au passage que les produits
issus du travail forcé consommé en
France
représente un chiffre d'affaires annuel
de 12 milliards de dollars dont 8 pour
ceux en provenance de la Chine alors mes
chers amis pour toutes ces raisons le
groupe RDPI faudra votera en faveur de
cette résolution je vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Rachid temal
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain pour 9 minutes
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il y a des moments où notre chambre à
l'occasion de se hisser de ce grandir à
être à hauteur de l'histoire ce fut le
carré récemment avec l'adoption le 23
mai dernier du projet de loi relatif à
la restitution des biens culturels en
fait l'objet de spoliation dans le
contexte des perversions antimites entre
1933 et 34 et 30 et 45 pardon ou encore
avec l'adoption la résolution relative à
la reconnaissance de aussi des
astro-calédiens en mai en février
dernier pardon cela peut être le cas
également lors la proposition soit
proposition de la commémoration de la
pression d'Algérien à Paris le 171 que
j'avais l'honneur de présenter
c'est à nouveau le cas aujourd'hui je
vais ici remercier mais un niveau gel et
son groupe le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire d'avoir déposé
cet été
je veux aussi rendre hommage au Wiggo
même qui au risque de leur vie de celle
de leur famille témoignent et informe le
monde les Infor le monde de ces crimes
contre l'humanité que subissent leur
peuple
alors que nous apprêtons à voter une
résolution en tout cas je le souhaite
visons interdire l'importation de
produits issus du travail forcé je ne
peux m'empêcher d'avoir à esprit ce
triste parallèle consistant dans le fait
qu'il y a à peine trois semaines le 10
mai dernier et même le 23 mai dernier
également nous commions toutes et tous
la joie nationale des mémoires de la
traite de l'esclavage et de l'abolition
je ne veux pas non plus omettre que la
France et le premier état il démarre le
seul à avoir déclaré la traite négrière
et l'esclavage crime contre l'humanité
aussi mes chers collègues qui notre pays
pour faire évoluer
cette législation et de manière concrète
commençons d'abord par les faits ils
sont documentés et je crois
incontestables sur une enquête réalisée
par le chercheur allemand advans relevé
en 2020 au moins 2 millions d'habitants
aussi Yang issus des minorités ethniques
sont envoyés dans des camps de coton
pour y travailler de force
selon l'Organisation internationale du
travail je voulais guillemets le travail
forcé fait référence à des situations
dans lequel les personnes sont
contraintes de travailler par
l'utilisation de la violence ou de
l'intimidation ou des moyens plus
subtils comme l'accumulation de dettes
or c'est 11 millions de wilgour kazak et
autres peuples musulmans sont soumis à
contre policier totalitaire et soumis à
travail forcé
depuis 2017 des centaines de milliers
d'entre eux sont envoyés encore de
rééducation plus récemment les signes
gens police ont permis de mettre des
visages et des noms sur les victimes de
ses horreurs à titre d'exemple la plus
jeune des tenues s'appelle rail Omer et
n'a que 14 ans dans le sol canton rural
de konasher plus de 12% la population
adulte Ouigours se trouvait dans un de
ces camps ou dans une prison au cours
des années 2017-2018 soit un adulte sur
fin 2018 après avoir longuement nié leur
existence la Chine a reconnu l'existence
de ces cons
les présentant comme des lieux
sympathiques de formation
professionnelle
une véritable honte
de nouveaux documents viennent confirmer
visuellement les récits de ces personnes
emprisonnées
où règnent dans des camps aux règnes la
torture les viols la violence les
mauvais traitements ou le lavage de
cerveau quand évoqué parmi parmi les
intervenants précédents
un rapport du cours mystériaire des
Nations Unies au droit de l'homme dirigé
par Michel à l'époque oubliez le 31 août
2021 à la fin de son mandat parce que
chacun se souvient du blocage de la
Chine à l'époque consacré à la région
autonome Ouigours du shinyang concluait
que de graves violations de droits de
l'homme sont commises dans ce dans ce
dans cette province à l'encon des Hugo
et d'autres communautés majoritairement
musulmanes
subissent à la fois les conséquences
d'un libéralisme fou où il faut produire
beaucoup moins cher mais également d'un
emprisonnement numérique où ils sont
aussi joyeux cobayes d'une pratique
numérique de l'État chinois
effectivement de surcroît une
éradication organisée de leur culture de
leur religion de leur peuple notamment
la stérilisation de nombreuses femmes
l'assemblée un autre fier à voter en
janvier 2022 une résolution portant sur
la reconnaissance et la condamnation du
caractère génocidaire de ces violences
en 2022 soit il y a un an le Parlement
européen adopté deux résolutions l'une
sur le fichier la situation des droits
de l'homme
rossignant y compris les fichiers de la
police et l'autre sur un nouvel
instrument commercial visant interdire
les produits issus du travail forcé
preuve s'il en était que ces initiatives
démocratiques ne laissent pas de marbre
le régime de Pékin celui-ci avait un
représenté sanctionné sanctionné 2021
une dizaine de ressorts européens dont
deux parlementaires dont le français
Raphaël Glucksman je vais aussi rappeler
que ces sanctions contre des élus qui
font tout simplement le travail pour
lequel ils ont reçu mandat sont
parfaitement inacceptables et
condamnable et nous devons les condamner
à chaque fois que nécessaire
sa dernière résolution européenne a
conduit à la Commission à présenter une
proposition visant interdire aux
fabricant producteurs et fournisseurs de
mettre sur le marché européen ou
d'exporter vers des pays tiers des
produits suit du travail forcé il
appartiendra à chaque État chaque État
dorénavant de faire la preuve des
soupçons qui sont portés
les marchandises en question seront
saisies et retirées du marché européen
mais comme l'ont évoqué mais précédent
aux orateurs il est présentateurs c'est
vrai que si on peut on constater une
avancée pour autant elle n'est pas
suffisante ne va pas dans le bon sens et
donc c'est pour ça que le texte nous
examinons aujourd'hui va dans le bon
sens lui puisqu'il invite les instances
européennes à réviser cette proposition
s'inspirant à disposition mais en oeuvre
par les États-Unis qui interdisent les
produits a priori font peser la
responsabilité sur les entreprises qui
doivent démontrer qu'ils n'utilisent pas
qui n'utilisent pas qu'une vente pas de
produits
issus du travail forcé
cette mesure aurait pour vertu de
s'appliquer plus rapidement et regarde
obligations en matière de trace
habituelle devrait pas normalement poser
de problème aux grands acteurs même si
il faut que les 83 entreprises
concernées puissent à nouveau démontrer
qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui les otages
en tout cas les clients de travail forcé
il faut savoir il faut le savoir chacune
et chacun d'entre nous chaque personne
qui porte un vêtement un accessoire qui
comprend un moins un autre
un élément de la chaîne de production
une fibre de coton produite en Chine
doit envisager la forte probabilité
d'être à son insu bénéficiaire d'un
travail forcé des Wiko
mes chers collègues il nous faut leur
affirmer haut et fort le seul
responsable de ces exercices c'est le
gouvernement chinois et notre assemblée
va par cette mesure je l'espère voter
collectivement démontrer le dire haut et
fort qu'il faut condamner le choix des
autorités chinoises et soutenir la
population ouigo
j'ajouterai pour conclure que d'après
les données de l'OIT dans le monde
environ près de 30 millions de personnes
sont actuellement soumises au travail
forcé
dans 86% dans des économies privées 14%
dans l'économie l'économie imposée par
l'État cette situation n'est pas
acceptable nulle part en Chine comme
ailleurs et donc vous l'aurez compris le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicains votera bien aimant cette
proposition de résolution et remercie et
ça lui effectivement une nouvelle fois
la proposition faite par nos collègues
du groupe et Madame Mélanie Vogel je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur fabienquet gay pour le groupe
CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je veux
commencer par remercier le groupe
écologiste pour la proposition de
résolution visant à interdire
l'importation de produits
issus du travail de la population ouigo
du cimetière
sans réserve et fortement nous
condamnons les crimes de masse commis à
l'encon de cette population le rapport
issu l'enquête du Haut commissariat au
droit de l'homme de l'ONU présente des
éléments probants travail forcé mais
aussi séparation des familles comme
travail application brutale et
discriminatoire la politique de contrôle
des naissances jusqu'à la stérilisation
forcée torture ou encore viol
il n'utilise cependant pas encore la
qualification génocidaire contrairement
à la résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui vous savez nos réserves
quant à l'utilisation de ce terme tant
que l'ONU n'a pas statué officiellement
il n'en reste pas moins que ce rapport
et les nombreuses enquêtes journalistes
suffit à nous conforter pour dire
clairement notre condamnation de la
répression de masse conduite à
l'encontre de la population Wiko nous
appelons d'ailleurs la Chine à permettre
une enquête indépendante le plus
rapidement sur son territoire si ces
crimes sont à examiner au niveau de
l'ONU les États ne doivent pas pour
autant rester silencieux cette
résolution s'attaque à un volet qui peut
être adressé tant au niveau national
Corps européen l'interdiction de produit
issue du travail forcé de la population
ouigo en Chine mes chers collègues dans
la fraternité humaine et la solidarité
il ne peut avoir Nitri ni de poids ni de
mesure notre groupe comme toujours comme
dans toutes les oppressions
commis contre un peuple ou une minorité
non seulement les exactions commises à
l'encontre des populations Ouigours mais
aussi celles infligées aux Palestiniens
par la colonisation israélienne au
saharaoui toujours nier par le pouvoir
marocain au peuple cubain qui subit un
blocus américains supportable
orienta victime des persécutions
Birmanie en Corée du Nord qui subit le
régime dictatorial ou l'invasion encore
de l'Ukraine par la Russie de Poutine si
nous partageons l'objectif de cette
résolution d'interdire l'importation des
produits issus du travail forcé nous ne
comprenons donc pas la demande d'une
révision du projet de règlement européen
visant à réduire son objet au seul cas
des Ouigours là où la résolution
européenne certes imparfaite maintient
du point au moins un champ d'application
potentiellement plus large de plus la
référence à la résolution américaine
prolongée par Biden en 2021 dans la
foulée des sanctions de Trump et
problématique
les décisions états-uniennes
s'inscrivent dans une logique de guerre
économique bien éloignée des motivations
de droit humain qu'il ne se prive pas de
fouler en bien d'autres occasions
partout sur la planète et notamment au
Moyen-Orient la lutte contre le travail
forcé ne doit pas connaître ni de
frontières ni de venir l'instrument à
géométrie variable vtcaire économique
car le travail forcé n'atte vient pas
uniquement dans les camps du chinchiang
d'après les chiffres de l'OIT il
concerne plus de 27 millions de
personnes hommes femmes et enfants sur
la planète par ailleurs trop de
population sont exploitées pour des
salaires misères qui ne suffisent pas à
vivre dignement 50 millions de personnes
sont dans des situations d'esclavage
moderne aucune région née épargnée
l'asile Pacifique compte plus de la
moitié du total mondial avec 15 millions
de travailleurs forcés et l'Europe et
l'Asie centrale ne sont pas à reste avec
près de 4 millions et 3,8 millions
personne sont concernées en Afrique
depuis 2017 la situation mondiale se
dégrade la pandémie de covid 19 les
conflits armés le changement climatique
les atteintes graves au Droit Humain
expose les populations aux risques
d'exploitation des surtout il ne
faut pas oublier que trop de
multinationales ça rendent coupable
attiré par la logique du profit maximal
elle trouve leur compte dans les États
autoritaires et dans le moins 10 ans
social et environnemental
dénonçons dès lors toutes les situations
de travail forcé qui font système dans
un monde ravagé par l'argent roi et qui
viennent avec nos traités de
libre-échange et nos logiques
commerciales dénonçons en raison ce
qu'il se passe en Chine mais aussi au
Moyen-Orient singulièrement au Qatar où
l'enfer des 40000 enfants travaillant
dans les mines de cobalt en république
Dominique du Congo interrogeons nos
modes de production et de consommation
socialement et écologiquement
irresponsable
pour lutter efficacement qu'on le fléau
du travail forcé exigeant des
certifications des entreprises sur leur
chaîne d'approvisionnement des secteurs
sont cités avec insistance dans le
rapporté agriculture mines industrie
manufacturière ou la construction mes
chers collègues même si nous avons une
divergence sur l'évolution restrictive
du règlement européen qui a réduré la
portée potentiellement universelle
l'ensemble - 2 collègues voteront la
proposition de la résolution que vous
nous avez présenté je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
la discussion la parole était Monsieur
Michel Calvet pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 8 minutes
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues la France est
un pays très attaché au droit de l'homme
n'oublions pas que notre prédécesseur
ici
Victor schœlcher qui a siégé ici au
Sénat a permis justement l'abolition de
l'esclavage soyons fiers de ces
décisions qu'il la prise un peu moins de
deux siècles
n'oublions pas non plus que la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme a été signé en France le siècle
dernier cette déclaration des droits de
l'homme dans le son d'article 4 et son
article 5 précise bien que nul ne doit
être tenu à l'esclavage nulle doit être
soumis à l'esclavage pardon et puis nul
ne doit être l'objet de ces vis et il
faut que nous nous attachons justement à
ce que à travers le monde cette
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme soit la plus
contacter dans les valeurs parce que ce
sont des valeurs tout à fait
fondamentales de notre pays et puis la
France est aussi bien sûr attachée à
l'expression de l'ensemble des minorités
que ce soit les minorités régionales je
suis pour ma part élu de Bretagne et
donc attaché à ce que sur la Bretagne la
liberté de conscience la liberté d'aller
de venir puisse être respectée et ce qui
est vrai en Bretagne doit être vrai dans
d'autres régions françaises et doit être
vrai bien entendu à travers l'ensemble
du monde et il nous faut donc à cet
égard en permanence
œuvré pour faire en sorte que cette
liberté soit effectivement
pratiquée un peu partout sur le monde
alors notre collègue Rachid Thema tout à
l'heure a évoqué le fait que à travers
le monde encore on recense l'OIT sens 30
millions de personnes qui sont soumises
au travail forcé et bien entendu pour
nous qui sommes attachés aux de liberté
nous ne pouvons l'accepter et il nous
faut bien entendu le dénoncer nous
indigner de tout cela et je partage
aussi
le propos qu'a tenu tout à l'heure notre
collègue Fabien gay évoquant notamment
la proposition d'une commission
d'enquête internationale qui pourrait
effectivement se rendre en République
populaire de Chine de façon à pouvoir
identifier réellement ce qui s'y passe
et pouvoir apporter justement
l'épreuve irréfutable de
de comportement que nous dénonçons que
nous devons dénoncer donc tout ceci bien
sûr doit nous rendre attentif à la
situation des populations minoritaires
qui subissent à travers le monde
particulièrement cela a été cité en
République populaire de Chine le travail
forcé les conflits on le sait bien à
travers le monde hélas
poursuivre nous avons tous bien sûr
en mémoire à l'instant le conflit qui
concerne l'Ukraine hier dans cette
émission que nous évoquions également la
situation de l'Arménie où nous devons
dénoncer aussi une situation de
privation de liberté et force est de
reconnaître que face à ces situations
contre lesquelles parfois nous sommes
démunis il faut agir et le moyen d'agir
que nous avons décidé internationalement
communément à l'égard de la Russie par
exemple qui a attaqué l'Ukraine c'est
bien les sanctions économiques alors il
est bien évident que
l'utilisation des sanctions économiques
dans un monde où l'échange des biens et
des marchandises et de plus en plus
important constitue certainement une
arme qu'il nous faut utiliser pour faire
en sorte que nous puissions exprimer
notre réprobation face à des
comportements ou
des recours que nous dénonçons par
ailleurs voilà je ne poursuivrai pas
plus en avant au titre du groupe de
l'Union centriste qui est
particulièrement attaché aux valeurs
humanistes valeurs libérale sociale
européenne qui les membres du groupe de
l'Union centriste bien entendu qui à
chaque fois qu'ils en ont l'occasion
notamment au titre des groupes d'amitié
font valeur font valoir c'est valeurs
françaises liées aux droits de l'homme
que nous voulons défendre et nous le
faisons bien entendu à chaque fois pour
ce qui concerne très précisément le
texte qui a été préparé par nos
collègues du groupe écologistes je dois
vous dire que si sur le fond nous
n'avons pas grand chose à redire sur la
forme néanmoins
nous devons regretter deux choses la
première chose c'est que pour ce qui
concerne l'instauration des sanctions
telles qu'elles sont proposées la charge
de la preuve va être très difficile à
établir et donc tout ceci doit nous
amener quand même à être prudent
certains diront que cela est irréfutable
mais pour nous le doute persiste et donc
cela nous apparaît comme étant
particulièrement difficile à mettre en
oeuvre et puis il faut le dire
s'agissant de texte relatifs aux droits
de l'homme tel que nous l'examinons à
l'instant nous nous pensons qu'il vaut
mieux avoir une approche qui soit
transpartisanale parce que cela a
beaucoup plus de poids plutôt que
d'avoir une initiative isolée d'un
groupe qui amène le texte avec
peut-être un certain nombre une certaine
façon de voir mais une façon de voir qui
n'est pas intégralement partagée et ceci
doit donc nous amener à la prudence et
je dois vous dire que donc les membres
du groupe de l'Union centriste attachée
comme je l'ai évoqué aux valeurs qui
font de notre République et que nous
souhaitons partager vont néanmoins à
l'exception de trois collègues
s'abstenir sur ce texte pour les raisons
que je viens d'évoquer
merci de votre attention si chers
collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
Esther Benbassa pour le groupe des non
inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues vous avez
certainement entendu parler de Shane
allégorie de la fastation t-shirt à 2
euros robe à 9 euros et accessoires de
mode défiant toute concurrence tel est
le prix de l'esclavage moderne le 5 mai
c'est en scène chinoise a ouvert en
plein coeur de notre capitale et pour la
seconde fois une boutique éphémère ou
des milliers de Français se sont
précipités pour effectuer des achats
à qui pouvons-nous jeter la pierre au
consommateurs qui faisant face à
l'inflation souhaite acheter en moindre
coût ou au gouvernement qui permet que
ce géant chinois exploitant les
oies comme main d'oeuvre forcée
s'installe librement sur notre sol en
toute impunité la marque Shane
enregistre un chiffre d'affaires de 30
millions d'euros et pourtant elle ne
rémunère ses employés aux gourde qu'une
poignée de centimes cela bien entendu
sans contrat de travail et avec des
conditions on ne peut plus exécrable le
9 juin 2022 la veille de la Journée
nationale de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavage le Parlement
européen a cherché à protéger le peuple
Hugo en interdisant l'import de produits
issus de leur travail forcé mais sans
s'en donner véritablement les moyens
si la réalité des persécutions que
subissent ce peuple ne fait plus débat
si la nature même d'un génocide ce
profil l'effectivité limitée des mesures
européennes nous invitent à vouloir
aller plus loin pour défendre le respect
des droits de l'homme trop d'enseignes
de géants de la mode que nous avons tous
fréquentés au moins une fois font des
profits colossaux en vendant ces
articles produits en Chine au mépris des
droits de l'homme en avril dernier le
combat des ONG envers ses pratiques a
été classée sans suite le besoin de
nouveaux instruments apparait évident la
proposition de résolution dont nous
débattons aujourd'hui visent à assurer
une meilleure traçabilité afin que
soient démontré que ces produits
importés ne soient pas issus du travail
forcé ouigo
et que l'industrie textile pour ne citer
qu'elle ne puisse plus se cacher
derrière son ignorance chers collègues
puisque tout reste à faire que des
textes ambitieux sont nécessaires
apportant notre soutien à cette cause
juste pour que l'Histoire ne puisse
plus tard nous jugeait pour notre
inaction adoptons aujourd'hui cette
résolution ne disons pas plus tard que
nous ne le savions pas merci merci chers
collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
de Monsieur André guillol pour le groupe
RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
je tiens tout d'abord remercier le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire pour leur initiative
permettant la tenue de ce débat sur le
triste sort de la population ouigo
au lendemain décrit ME contre l'humanité
commis dans des camps de concentration
par les régimes totalitaires d'Hitler ou
de Staline on croyait avoir tourné la
page d'une telle barbarie et bien non
21e siècle nous devons encore déplorer
des tragédies humanitaires depuis
maintenant plusieurs années la
République populaire de Chine bafoue les
droits humains de la population ouigo et
d'autres peuples turciques et ceux dans
une certaine indifférence de la
communauté internationale
les auteurs de la proposition de
résolution l'ont rappelé les wigoux
représentent la population chinoise
musulmane originaire du quotidieng une
vaste région historiquement connue et
des points de contact entre la Chine et
le Moyen-Orient
les faits sont très documentés les
Ouigours sont soumis à des arrestations
arbitraires à la déportation au travail
forcé et à des violences morales et
physiques
dans les centres d'internement et
d'endoctrinement où ces derniers sont
enfermés et subissent des pires
supplices parmi lesquels de façon
systématique des flagellations des
électrifications des stérilisations et
des avortements forcés et des viols
comme si cela ne suffisait pas pour bien
marquer la raison de cet acharnement les
houilles gourds se voient infliger des
pratiques allant à l'encontre du libre
exercice de leur culte tels que
l'ingestion forcée de port ou d'alcool
et l'interdiction de prier les autorités
chinoises font preuve d'une indignation
terrifiante un pardon d'imagination
terrifiante et sans borne j'ajouterai
que ces atrocités n'ont pas de limite
d'âge ou de genre
on dénombre dans ces cas environ un ou
deux millions de femmes d'hommes
également des enfants séparés de leur
famille ils sont soumis au même
conditions de vie et de l'autre que
leurs aînés notamment en matière de
travail forcé si ces crimes se déroulent
très loin de nous gardons à l'esprit que
chaque ouigo de la diaspora vivant en
France compte au moins un proche dans
les cas ne concentration les prisons ou
dans les usines de travail forcé du
régime chinois
selon un groupe d'avocats des experts
des droits humains il s'agit de
véritables génocide car les autorités
chinoises comme on le sait souhaiter
radiquer une population en raison de sa
confession et la rééduquer ainsi aux
biens culturellement que aussi bien
culturellement que politiquement
face à cela que pour nous faire que
pouvons nous faire sans aucun doute
dénoncé boycotter les multinationales
comme le groupe français SMCP qui
détient Sandro mage et Claudie Pierlot
l'espagnol Inditex avec Zara et sherka
ou encore chêne ça a été dit à l'instant
qui profite d'un travail forcé de cette
population dans une démarche de profit à
tout prix
leur succès commerciaux ont le goût du
sang quand il lit les principes
d'organisation internationales du
travail
condamnant l'esclavage le travail forcé
le travail des enfants toute forme de
discrimination raciale de torture et de
sentiments cruels faut-il appeler aussi
que l'article 3 de la Constitution de la
République populaire de Chine qui
dénonce que l'État respecte qui énonce
pardon et que l'État respecte et
garantit les droits de l'homme au mépris
de son propre texte fondamental et des
textes fondateurs du droit humanitaire
international les tâches chinois commet
en toute impunité ses crimes avec la
complicité des grandes multinationales
la communauté la communauté
internationale de la France
dont la France toujours écoutée en tant
que membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU a le devoir de
protéger la population ouigo
cela fera bientôt deux ans que les
États-Unis ont promulgué un texte de loi
qui est interdit l'achat de produits qui
serait fabriqué en partie ou totalement
aussi Chang de son côté l'Europe avance
timidement ménageant la Chine disons-le
pour des raisons économiques et
diplomatiques que nous connaissons
toutefois regardons comment la Russie
nous rend la bienveillance que nous
avions pourtant toujours eu à son égard
jusqu'à la veille de son agression
contre l'Ukraine la peur de contrarier
n'évite pas le danger dans ces
conditions la France doit s'impliquer
pour la mise en place de l'embargo
européen strict sur les produits issus
de travail forcé le dispositif de la
Commission européenne doit être revu en
faveur d'un dispositif clair et
opérationnel donc à affrontir les
importations entacées de son ouigo ainsi
le groupe RDSE approuve la proposition
de résolution et la votera je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à la présidente Pascal grunis pour
le groupe républicains pour 9 minutes
dis donc monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues en dépit de ces dénégations
obstinées malgré la chape de plomb qu'il
fait peser sur tout un pays et
spécialement sur ses provinces de
l'Ouest le régime chinois ne parvient
plus à dissimuler la nature de ces
agissements contre la minorité ouigo
depuis plusieurs années en effet les
témoignages de persécution qui nous
parviennent de la région du Cynthia sont
à la fois de plus en plus nombreux de
plus en plus précis mais aussi de mieux
en mieux étayer par une pluralité
d'enquête et de rapports internationaux
surveillant généralisé restrictions
religieuses et linguistiques arrestation
arbitraires internement de masse travail
forcé viol systématisé stérilisation
torture la gravité des accusations qui
pèsent sur Pékin est accablante
à ce jour leurs qualification exacte
fait encore l'objet de nombreux débats
d'experts mais qu'on la nomme violation
grave des droits fondamentaux crime
contre l'humanité ou bien génocide la
réalité du supplice vécu par les
Ouigours elle ne peut plus
raisonnablement être mise en doute face
à ce constat s'impose chaque jour avec
davantage de force la réaction
internationale se distingue pourtant par
sa retenue le récent rapport du
Haut-Commissariat au droit de l'homme à
matérialiser une prise de conscience
réelle sur ce sujet mais la polarisation
du monde conjuguée à la prépondérance
croissante de la Chine dans toutes les
dimensions des relations internationales
risque d'entraver encore longtemps la
réponse des instances multilatérales
moyens d'actions doivent donc être
explorés l'Union européenne a ainsi
décidé en 2021 conjointement avec
d'autres pays occidentaux de hausser le
ton et d'adopter des mesures
restrictives ces sanctions les premières
visant la Chine depuis tienamen ont
constitué un signal politique et
diplomatique majeur qu'il ne faut pas
sous-estimer mais en se contentant de
geler les avoir d'une poignée de
responsables chinois et en leur
interdisant de pénétrer sur le
territoire européen leur ampleur
apparaît il est vrai bien modestes au
regard des faits incriminés il était
donc important que la réponse européenne
puisse franchir une nouvelle étape mais
aussi qu'elle dépasse le seul terrain
diplomatique pour viser également le
champ des échanges commerciaux fondement
de la puissance chinoise
nous savons tous qu'on vient notre
relation à la Chine et tout
particulièrement notre relation
commerciale est un sujet délicat sur
lequel est sensibilités et les intérêts
des États membres ne s'alignent pas
spontanément très attendu la proposition
de règlement européen sur l'interdiction
des produits issus du travail forcé et
donc à ce titre une initiative qui
mérite d'être saluée et soutenu
certes le projet de texte ne vise pas
spécifiquement la Chine puisqu'il
prévoit que tous les biens issus du
travail forcé devront être bannis du
marché européen et ce quel que soit sa
provenance
et pour cause l'OIT nous rappelait
encore récemment que près de 28 millions
de personnes sur les 5 continents
étaient touchés par cette forme
d'esclavage moderne néanmoins ce large
cadre géographique ne devrait pas
empêcher l'Europe de cibler ses efforts
contre le travail forcé en effet les
autorités chargées d'appliquer la
législation devront adopter une approche
fondée sur les risques en d'autres
termes elles devront orienter leurs
investigations en priorité vers les
zones et les secteurs présentant les
plus forts risques de travail forcé
pour se faire elles devront prendre en
compte les informations émanant de
nombreuses sources telles que les
témoignages individuels les éléments
communiqués par les ONG ou encore les
données recueillies auprès des
entreprises notamment dans le cadre de
l'exercice de leurs devoir de vigilance
les autorités pourront en outre
s'appuyer sur les travaux de leurs
homologues européens réunis au sein d'un
nouveau réseau contre les produits
issus du travail forcé ainsi que sur les
orientations fournies par la Commission
européenne au travers des lignes
directrices des indicateurs de risque et
de la base de données qu'elle publiera
ainsi dans la pratique et au vu de la
Somme d'information déjà collectés à ce
jour l'application de ce dispositif
aboutira inévitablement à placer le
xinkyang et ses exportations au sommet
de la liste des enquêtes à menées par
les autorités nationales la proposition
de résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui suggère néanmoins une
approche différente de celle que
préconise la Commission dans un premier
temps ces auteurs invitent l'Union
européenne à renforcer ses sanctions
contre les auteurs des crimes perpétrés
contre la communauté ouigo je crois que
nous pouvons tous sur ce point nous
retrouver et considérer que les mesures
actuellement places méritent d'être à la
fois approfondie et élargie dans un
second temps il est proposé d'introduire
au sein du projet de règlement européen
un régime spécifique à la région du King
Chiang
selon les termes de l'exposé des motifs
il s'agirait de mettre en place un
embargo sur les produits issus du
travail forcé de la population ouigo
comment là encore ne pas souscrire un
tel objectif mais le système proposé par
nos collègues me laisse en revanche plus
dubitative en effet celui-ci
s'inspirerait du mécanisme mis en oeuvre
depuis un an par les États-Unis et qui
prévoit que les marchandises en Provence
du xincent soit automatiquement réputé
enfreindre l'interdiction de travail
forcé sauf à ce que l'importateur puisse
prouver le contraire d'une manière
claire et convaincante dès lors avec le
texte qui nous est proposé il
n'appartiendrait plus aux autorités de
prouver une infraction mais aux
entreprises de démontrer son absence qui
plus est hors de tout doute disons-le
d'emblée dans le labyrinthe des chaînes
d'approvisionnement modernes éliminer ce
doute sera quasiment impossible tant il
est complexe pour une entreprise et
spécialement pour une PME de connaître
l'ensemble des acteurs participant à la
fabrication d'un produit à ce titre il
est important de souligner que si
l'enchevêtrement des chaînes de valeur
peut s’avérer un obstacle
infranchissable pour les entreprises la
proposition de réglement européen fait
en sorte qu'il n'en soit pas de même
pour les autorités en effet celle-ci
pourront interdire la commercialisation
d'un produit même si tous les éléments
prouvant qu'il est issu du travail forcé
n'ont pas pu être réunis dans ce
contexte une inversion de la charge de
la preuve n'apparaît pas véritablement
indispensable mais surtout en raison de
la responsabilité exorbitante et des
risques de non-conformité qu'elle ferait
peser sur les entreprises cette mesure
risque de les inciter à se désengager
toute activité en lien avec le signe
l'exemple américain nous fournit
d'ailleurs un précédent instructif
puisque nombre d'entreprises américaines
ou non ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu'elle cesserait purement et simplement
de s'y approvisionner afin de maintenir
leur accès au marché américain et
d'éviter tout risque de sanction à la
lumière de cet exemple il est à craindre
que l'embarco proposait par nos
collègues sur les produits du travail
forcé des ouigo ne se transforme en
embargo tout court prévoir ainsi toute
la province d'une grande partie des
débouchés sur lesquels repose
actuellement son activité économique je
crois donc qu'il faut aussi et peut-être
avant tout mesurer pleinement les effets
secondaires que pourrait avoir un tel
embargo sur la population du xyang et
donc sur les huit Gourgues
plus largement chacun a pris conscience
ces dernières années que la traçabilité
et la responsabilisation des chaînes
d'approvisionnement étaient désormais
des impératifs incontournables mais il
m'apparaît essentiel sur ce sujet
d'éviter les ruptures et d'aventer pas à
pas essentiel aussi d'adopter une
logique partenariale entre des états
légitimement de plus en plus exigeants
et des entreprises de plus en plus mises
à contribution mais aussi il faut le
souligner de plus en plus engagé c'est
pourquoi même si nous comprenons
l'objectif porté par ce texte le
dispositif proposé ne nous semble pas le
plus opportun et le groupe les
républicains s'abiendra donc sur cette
proposition de résolution je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur jean-Louis
Lagourgue pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec son
développement économique spectaculaire
et ses prouesses technologiques nous
pourrions presque oublier que la Chine
est communiste l'enfer des camps nous le
rappelle depuis la fin du 20e siècle et
plus encore depuis 2014 le Parti
communiste et chinois emploie les grands
moyens pour régler son problème ouigo
cette minorité ethnique de 11 millions
de personnes et la cible d'une
persécution génocidaire ce Couvet de
lutte contre l'islamisme et les
dirigeants chinois enferment grande
échelle cette population dans la droite
ligne totalitaire communiste le parti
organise la rééducation des individus à
travers un système concentrationnel
avec sa discipline de faire il tend de
briser les consciences et la croyance
religieuse par l'endoctrinement
le marxisme n'ayant jamais été très
convaincant le parti recourt volontiers
aux séances de torture au viol et au
travail forcé
la rééducation criminelle en elle-même
n'est cependant cependant qu'une façade
pour régler le problème les autorités
chinoises entreprennent de le faire
disparaître le Conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'ONU les accusés ainsi de
procéder à des campagnes de
stérilisation forcées le but est
d'effacer la culture ouigo la langue
ouigo mais aussi la minorité rubrique
oui dans son ensemble
ces actes portent atteinte à l'humanité
et déshonneur la Chine millénaire les
appels plus ferme condamnation c'est le
sens du présent texte déposé par le
groupe écologiste sans se contenter de
saluer l'initiative de nos collègues
notre groupe a cosigné cette résolution
à l'unanimité le martyre de ouigo on est
l'aspect un cas isolé avant eux il est
déjà eu tous ceux qui furent des
chrétiens nationalistes contre
révolutionnaires et les militants des
droits humains ont encore les Tibétains
50 millions de personnes sont passées
par les camps du parti 20 millions qui
sont mortes
ce n'est pas un hasard si la Chine a
toujours eu recours à l'emprisonnement
en masse comment pourrait-il en être
autrement
car hors la majorité de la majorité ne
peut se trouver que les ennemis du
peuple la réalisation du bien commun
implique la surveillance et le contrôle
des individus il faut s'assurer de leur
obéissance et les privés de moyens se
poser ainsi disparaissent le droit de
propriété et la liberté à tel système
carcéral coûte cher pour le maintenir
les autorités chinoises équilibrent les
finances en recourant au travail forcé
aujourd'hui comme hier les détenus
travaillent sans relâche entre les
séances de torture et d'autocritique
les marchandises issues du travail forcé
sont souillés de sang des victimes du
régime communiste défenseurs de la
liberté nous ne pouvons pas commencer
avec cette commercer avec ces fois c'est
fossoyeurs la résolution propose qu'elle
ne franchissent pas nos frontières nous
ne pouvons que la prouver
par sa consignatures et par son vote à
l'unanimité le groupe Les Indépendants
affirme son opposition à toutes les
oppressions les Wiggo comme toutes les
minorités comme tous les individus ont
droit au respect de leur liberté je vous
remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier best
ministre délégué chargé du Commerce
extérieur de l'attractivité des Français
de l'étranger
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
mesure la gravité du sujet qui m'amène
aujourd'hui à prendre la parole devant
vous à l'occasion de l'examen de cette
proposition de résolution visant à
interdire l'importation des produits
issus du travail forcé de la population
Ouigours en République populaire de
Chine depuis plusieurs années la
situation des droits de l'homme au CIM
Jong fait l'objet des plus vifs
préoccupations les témoignages et des
rapports étayés ont notamment fait état
d'internement de masse et de détention
arbitraire de disparition forcée de
violences sexuelles de surveillance
généralisée ainsi que de travail forcé
lequel est au cœur de la proposition de
résolution examinée aujourd'hui
ces informations étaient confirmées par
les conclusions du rapport du Haut
Commissariat des Nations Unies au droit
de l'homme sur la situation des droits
de l'homme au ciné Djang publié en août
2022 celui-ci souligne également que
l'ampleur de la détention arbitraire et
discriminatoire subies par les personnes
wego et d'autres groupes après dominance
musulmanes pourrait être constitutive de
crimes internationaux en particulier de
crimes contre l'humanité s'agissant des
allégations de travail forcé le rapport
du HCDH constate des éléments de
coercition dans les programmes de
travail et d'emploi au ciné il rejoint à
cet égard les conclusions du rapporteur
général des Nations Unies sur les formes
contemporaines d'esclavage y compris
leurs causes et leurs conséquences
Thomas au bocata qui estimait en juillet
2022 pouvoir raisonnablement conclure
que des huit gours et des Casa qui et
des membres d'autres minorités ethniques
ont été soumis au travail forcé dans des
secteurs tels que l'agriculture et
l'industrie manufacturière dans la
région autonome huit gourds du cymes en
Chine
face à la gravité de la situation aussi
Diane la France est pleinement mobilisée
à tous les niveaux tout d'abord dans le
cadre du dialogue étroit et exigeant
qu'elle mène avec la Chine la France
évoque les droits de l'homme en Chine en
particulier au Cynthia lors des
entretiens bilatéraux jusqu'au plus haut
niveau nous relayons auprès des
autorités chinoises de préoccupations
partagées par l'opinion publique
française quant à l'ampleur et la
gravité des violations au signe Djang et
appelons à y mettre fin le président de
la République c'est à lui-même c'est
lui-même à plusieurs reprises exprimées
publiquement avec force à ce sujet
l'ambassade de France en Chine poursuit
en dépit d'un contexte difficile son
action de soutien à la société civile et
aux militants des droits de l'Homme
s'agissant de notre territoire national
les autorités françaises sont très
attentives au respect des droits
fondamentaux des 8 gours établit en
France ainsi qu'à leur sécurité comme
toutes les personnes présentes sur notre
territoire qu'elles soient de
nationalité française ou étrangère au
niveau européen notre action a pris une
dimension nouvelle avec l'adoption de
sanctions le 22 mars 2021 au titre du
régime transversal de sanctions de
l'Union européenne en matière de droits
de l'homme parmi les personnes et
entités sanctionnées quatre individus et
une entité ont été désignées pour leur
responsabilité dans les violations des
droits de l'homme perpétrés au Cynthia
ces mesures constituées une première
depuis les sanctions adoptées en 1989 le
signe Djang a également fait l'objet
d'échanges approfondie via à l'occasion
de la 38e session de dialogue Union
européenne Chine sur les droits de
l'homme du 17 février 2023 et la réunion
trilatérale du 6 avril entre la
présidente de la commission le président
de la République et le Président si Jean
Ping en lien avec la situation des
droits de l'homme en Chine et au signe
John il convient de mentionner également
l'accord global sur les investissements
entre l'Union européenne et la Chine
l'Union européenne s'était attachée à y
introduire des engagements formels de
respect des conventions fondamentales de
l'Organisation internationale du travail
notamment celle relative au travail
forcé
cette vigilance européenne a eu des
résultats avec la ratification par la
Chine des conventions fondamentales
numéro 29 et 105 de l'OIT sur le travail
forcé
bien sûr au-delà de la ratification la
question de leur mise en oeuvre est
toujours présente dans nos échanges avec
Pékin par ailleurs comme vous le savez
le processus de ratification de cet
accord sur les investissements est
interrompu depuis que la Chine a
sanctionné des élus et des
parlementaires en particulier des
parlementaires européens ensuite
concerne les enceintes internationales
la France ils soutient systématiquement
les déclarations et les résolutions de
la situation aussi Djang prononcer en
troisième commission à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies et au Conseil
des droits de l'homme ainsi le 6 octobre
dernier lors de la 51e session la France
a appelé à tenir un débat à la suite de
la publication du rapport du HCDH sur la
situation des droits de l'homme dans la
région autonome ouigourt du Cynthia
après vous avoir exposé les différents
piliers de notre politique en matière de
droits de l'homme aussi Jiang je
voudrais en venir au sujet de la lutte
contre le travail forcé et au devoir de
vigilance des entreprises
l'engagement de la France dans ce
domaine et vous le savez pionnier
la France est le premier pays au monde à
s'être doté dès 2017 d'une loi sur le
devoir de vigilance des sociétés maires
et des entreprises de noces d'ordre
cette loi vise à identifier les risques
liés aux activités des entreprises et
alors chaîne de valeur afin de prévenir
atténuer et remédier les atteintes
graves au droit fondamentaux y compris
évidemment le travail forcé et à
l'environnement elle impose aux
entreprises d'établir un plan de
vigilance inclus dans le rapport de
gestion de l'entreprise nous conduisons
à cette fin des actions de
sensibilisation pour veiller à ce que le
secteur privé prenne sa part de
responsabilité pour lutter contre le
travail forcé
notre objectif aujourd'hui et que
l'Union européenne prenne des mesures à
la hauteur des enjeux c'est pourquoi la
France a fait du capitalisme responsable
une des priorités de la présidence
française du Conseil de l'Union
européenne au premier semestre 2022 dans
ce cadre elle a pris une part active à
l'élaboration du projet de directives
sur le devoir de vigilance des
entreprises en matière de durabilité
présentée par la Commission en février
2022 et elle continue de mettre son
expérience accumulée grâce à sa loi
nationale au service de la négociation
en cours elle participe également
activement aux travaux en cours en vue
d'adopter un règlement pour interdire
pour tous les opérateurs économiques la
mise sur le marché européen de produits
issus du travail forcé qu'il soit
fabriqué sur le territoire de l'Union
Européenne ou importer ainsi que
l'exportation évidemment de tels
produits depuis l'Union européenne
la France sera donc attentive à ce que
le projet de règlement soit davantage
clarifié pour garantir son
opérationnalité et sa prévisibilité tant
pour les entreprises que pour les
autorités chargées de son application et
nous appelons à ce que les discussions
européennes s'accélèrent aujourd'hui sur
ce sujet
en outre le projet pas dans la France
déploie aussi sont d'action à l'échelle
mondiale et multilatérale pour lutter
contre le travail forcé elle promeut le
développement la ratification et
l'application effective des normes
internationales pour interdire le
travail forcé l'entrée en vigueur pour
la Chine des conventions fondamentales
numéro 29 et 105 de l'OIT sur le travail
forcé cet été déclenchera les mécanismes
de suivi et de contrôle qui sont prévus
pour ces conventions la vigilance du
gouvernement s'exerce aussi en matière
de financement du développement nous
contestons tout financement y compris
par l'intermédiaire des banques de
développement de projets susceptibles de
contribuer au travail forcé ou à la
répression notamment dans la région du
Cynthia
la France tient aussi au rôle moteur un
rôle moteur au sein de l'Alliance 8.7
partenariat mondial pour l'éradication
du travail forcé de l'esclavage moderne
de la traite des êtres humains et du
travail des enfants dans le monde dans
le cadre du G7 la France a signé
plusieurs déclarations politiques visant
à réaffirmer son engagement à lutter
contre le travail forcé à l'échelle
mondial dont la plus récente était à
Hiroshima le 20 mai 2023 la France est
aussi très active dans la négociation et
les discussions relatives à la conduite
responsable des entreprises au sein de
l'OCDE qui est l'enceinte de référence
en la matière ayant permis d'élaborer
des bonnes pratiques et des outils
concrets à l'intention des entreprises
ces différents exemples témoignent de
l'engagement de la France sur la
thématique du travail forcé tant au
niveau national que européen et
international vous aurez constaté une
grande convergence entre l'action du
gouvernement et les recommandations
contenues dans de proposition de
résolution parlementaire le travail
forcé constitue toutefois un problème
d'ampleur mondial que l'on ne saurait
circonscrire à une seule région c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous défendons une
réponse mondiale c'est la raison pour
laquelle la France comme l'Union
européenne privilégie une approche
transversale qui faite à la fois garante
d'efficacité et de conditions de
concurrence équitable mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la France
continuera de mener avec ses partenaires
européens un dialogue exigeant et disons
le difficile avec la Chine sur le
respect des droits de l'homme notamment
au CIM Jong en appelant en particulier
la Chine à ratifier le Pacte
international relatif aux droits civils
et politiques des Nations Unies nous
poursuivrons par ailleurs sans relâche
notre engagement afin que ce soit bien
prise en compte les objectifs fixés au
niveau européen en matière de respect
des droits de l'homme en Chine notamment
au signe Djang notamment dans le cadre
de la politique commerciale et
d'investissement dans les instances
internationales nous demeurons
pleinement mobiliser afin de défendre de
caractères universel et inaliénable des
droits de l'homme et d'exhorter la Chine
à respecter ces libertés fondamentales
conformément à ses obligations découlant
du droit national et international je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre nous allons
procéder au vote sur la proposition de
résolution la Conférence des Présidents
a décidé que les interventions des
orateurs valaient explications de vote
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe écologiste sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de
résolution il va être procédé de ce que
c'est un public dans les conditions
fixées par type 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
la beauté
le scrutin est clos
nombre de votants 343
exprimer 144 pour 144 contre 0 le Sénat
a adopté
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance la prochaine séance mardi 6 juin
2023 à 9h30 pour les questions orales la
séance est levée
[Musique]